[Music]
serial killer thriller has a shot of a
rainsoak street cliche tonight's tonight
dexteration every damn pilot and it's
going to happen again
and again and vague pronoun game playing
narration at that taking off that
generic pilot bingo card pretty quickly
aren't we guys why did mike donovan park
this far away from the festivities where
no one else was parked did he know he
needed to give dexter the opportunity to
kidnap and kill him you have to listen
and do what i say or you could get up
and run because dexter does not have a
weapon trained on you or you could just
let yourself get strangled some more
also this is such an awkward [ __ ] way
for dexter to drag donovan to wherever
they're going why not keep him standing
where he's less likely to slip out open
your eyes and look at what you did
dexter will soon inform us that he's
incapable of feeling emotion so what's
with all this uncontrollable rage and if
he's faking what's the point this is
about feeding dexter's appetite right
does he really care about the kids
i'm already full of grace the lord stop
that never helps anybody dexter is a
dick to prayers i couldn't help myself i
couldn't i did any sentence you can use
to defend why you just had to have one
more deliciously cream-filled twinkie
cannot also be used to defend murdering
children
i'm not going to sin needling this guy
without explicit consent because this
monster but i am going to send it
happening so quickly that i couldn't
look away in time you need my consent
too damn it soon
you'll be packed into a few
neatly wrapped hefties i wonder if this
is what hefty had in mind when they
agreed to product placement in this
episode also tv show thinks we'll root
for a serial killer just because he's
killing bad people and 96 episodes
across eight seasons and a relaunch
would seem to support that theory so
this sin is for you people we're going
to show you insane amounts of violence
and gore but no penis because that would
just be gross free the pain dexter free
the peen also come on man dexter clearly
got that saran wrap from costco you're
not even trying to wriggle out of that
maybe play strategically to hold you
down but that doesn't stop you from
putting up more of a fight than last
year's thanksgiving leftovers harry and
doris morgan did a wonderful job raising
me but they're both dead now i didn't
kill them just so we're clear this is a
show that feels the need to have its
main character say a line that assures
us he didn't kill his foster parents
this box contains enough damning
evidence to put dexter away from
multiple life sentences and this air
conditioning unit is the best place he
could think to hide it this is literally
the first place i would think to search
after i'd ruled out under the bed in the
secret safe behind his portrait of
hannibal lecter this show was released
in 2006 so why does it appear to be set
in 1998 both html4 and outlook 98 came
out in 1998 power builder 6 was released
in 97 and microsoft server 4 launched in
96 the [ __ ] is going on here i get the
lure of product placement but for
software that's a decade out of date you
better be a cop no forensics if this
[ __ ] thought dexter wasn't allowed at
the crime scene why the [ __ ] did it even
let him cross the police line and why
didn't dexter avoid this confrontation
by wearing his [ __ ] id evidently the
show was desperate to have dexter tell
us what his job is just in case we spent
the whole damn episode wondering why he
kept showing up at crime scenes with no
questions asked how does someone so dumb
get so much power sure is ironic that
someone that lives in florida would ask
this question i went out of ice and into
homicide what can i do to help it feels
like all of these police procedurals are
made up of a cop trying to prove
themselves and a quirky advisor who
helps them solve crimes what's
refreshing about this show however is
that because this is a sibling duo
there's no chance of turning that into a
[ __ ] will they or won't they
eventually hook up cliche right right
sorry sister
damn looking at masuka thinks it's
appropriate to talk about a fellow
colleague and dexter's [ __ ] sister in
this way go on dex add them to your list
we won't tell there's still random miami
residents looking in on the crime scene
masuka and batista couldn't wait until
they transported the body to show dexter
she had a nice ass too necrophilia tell
the families
good bill answering a question mid
mastication that you had plenty of time
to answer pre-mastication thanks for the
donut i gotta go only eating part of a
donut who [ __ ] does that debra is the
real monster of this series well i like
doing it maybe i can help out
fills my nights you have a morbid sense
of fun conversation with my family after
i told them about working for tv sins
somehow ends up wait am i dexter just
like me empty inside
was that meant to be some kind of
profound realization
many points for the attempt but for me
that was heavy-handed messy work all
that blood on the wall so it's like a
finger painting you give me a [ __ ]
creeps you know that dexter sergeant
dukes would be killer at tv sins and i
don't give a sh what you say because
that's what happened and that's who i'm
looking for hey
we are looking for a [ __ ] thief
dealer
you got it i can't argue with the worthy
cause of putting away thief dealers as
doke so eloquently puts it but aren't
you supposed to follow the evidence and
put away whoever the actual killer is as
well or can dokes not be an antagonist
to dexter unless he's also a shitty
police officer too he's putting the
gloves on now why not 30 seconds ago you
know when he was touching the [ __ ]
doorknob friday night date night in
miami every night is date night in miami
then why bother saying this as if it was
unique to fridays stop wasting our time
with redundant day descriptors public
displays of erection deb saved her life
on a domestic dispute call introduced us
and we've been dating for six months now
how did that conversation come about hey
i know you've been through some hideous
and unspeakable trauma uh you want to
date my foster brother
i never understood the compulsion to
insult the parents of the person you're
actually mad at son of all just be
direct calm
out of a good you know you might feel
better for it apparently you must be 21
dinner this website but by entering
you're acknowledging that you're only 18
years of age show doesn't know how to
website correctly i'm not expecting this
scumbag to win master criminal of the
year but you'd at least think you would
cover up this very easily identifiable
tattoo whilst making a snuff film that
is going to be posted on a website that
clearly advertises its own illegal
nature hey dad
i can explain kids okay so we can't stop
this but maybe we can do something to
channel it what do you mean we can't
stop this he's barely tried dexter's dad
jumps straight from allowing dexter to
kill animals too making sure he only
kills criminals what about running or
boxing or i don't know
therapy
there are people out there who do really
bad things so harry's plan is to have
his dangerous son track and find even
more dangerous people to kill putting
dexter in danger and probably the entire
morgan family while he's at it that is
some a-list parenting harry you ready
i'm gonna shame this [ __ ] saying that
loud enough for fellow officers around
dev to hear probably doesn't help her
case for being taken more seriously
refrigerated truck that that might give
us a lead that's very interesting very
creative let's keep looking for the
witness we get it laguerta hates morgan
but morgan's idea is still the best damn
lead they have truly cracking this case
will make luguerta look good too so why
is she just missing this idea out of
hand just because it came from someone
she dislikes especially when none of
these chuckle [ __ ] are coming up with
any groundbreaking ideas let's tell for
today that's [ __ ] all only one idea
was brought to the table and even that
was dismissed out of hand because the
person presenting it came with female
reproductive parts this briefing was as
futile as every time the army bigwigs
gathered to decide what the [ __ ] they're
going to do about the giant murder bots
from space tearing up the planet in
every transformers movie he sure as hell
took a sweet time slicing up that lady
and you don't do that unless you have a
close personal relationship with someone
this might be the point but i'm
struggling to get on board with dexter's
definition of a close and personal
relationship i'm watching you
[ __ ] lieutenant laguerta is
perfectly fine with this blatant example
of workplace intimidation jaworski's
been coming here for weeks likes to
steal all the copper plumbing there's
good money in that no security guards
someone's been coming here for weeks in
stealing copper plumbing but the site
manager hasn't thought to hire some
security knowing dexter i'm gonna assume
that this shrink wrap mask serves a
greater purpose than simply intimidation
since he's very conscious about not
leaving a trail it's fair to assume it's
also supposed to prevent him from
leaving behind any dna so why is he left
the top part with his hair exposed if
you're gonna look ridiculous you may as
well [ __ ] commit to it this cut is a
cut of lies any facial laceration bleeds
like the elevator doors just opened in
the shining i can't even shave without
eventually looking like a poorly wrapped
mummy by the end of it hello
hey
i'm sorry one of the things that makes
dexter stand out from other serial
killer shows is this juxtaposition of
normalcy while he's in the middle of
committing such a heinous act and
michael c hall makes it all very
believable with his performance the show
isn't perfect but when it gets things
right it kind of feels like it is not
simply calling this company miami ice is
a [ __ ] crime onto itself and i will
not stand for a wasted pun sir you know
you should call me maria i'll tell you
who's good you are attempting to seduce
a colleague mere minutes after they've
experienced having a severed head thrown
at them also lieutenant maria laguerta
is not my superior in this scene are you
okay as royally [ __ ] up as this
relationship is michael c hall and julie
benz have great chemistry and this is a
really interesting and unique tv romance
to watch while it lasts
all right i'll come get you cody just
threw up all over colleen's couch
where's colleen in this situation
shouldn't she be making that phone call
and if they're just next door why can't
she just bring the kids back [ __ ]
colleen randomly breaking the fourth
wall at the 51-minute mark of a
53-minute episode is random
a scratch your arm's off no it isn't but
what's that then i've heard worse do you
know what you look like to me with your
good bag and your cheap shoes you look
like a robe
a well-scrubbed hustling robe with a
little taste
good nutrition is giving you some length
of bone but you're not more than one
generation from poor wide trash
sorry sister
damn looking hot get off my sister
one thing sure inspector clay is dead
murdered
and somebody's responsible
surprise motherfu
the killer is an artist
what do you mean
you know i'm really wired
what do you say i
take you home and eat you
i'm afraid your urge to kills only gonna
get stronger urged to kill rising
surprise motherfu
surprise [ __ ]
you know i've been watching you all year
donny when you hit that shot to beat
fairfield and
you were jumping up and down in your
little larry bird short shorts and
sweating like a jar of pickles in the
hot sun